-Bonjour.
"Maman, j'ai arrêté l'avion"
se penche ce mois-ci
sur notre production
et consommation de viande.
Cette dernière a doublé
en Europe depuis 1960
et quintuplé dans le monde.
La viande est devenue
un marqueur de civilisation
et même,
un marqueur de virilité,
vitalité et progrès social.
A l'heure de l'urgence climatique,
le mythe du steak-frites
tel que décrit par Roland Barthes
a du plomb dans l'aile,
car la viande pèse lourd
dans nos émissions
de gaz à effet de serre.
Maman, j'ai arrêté la viande.
Générique
...
Un steak, ce sont des centaines
de litres d'eau consommée
et des kilos de CO2 émis,
Raphaël Hitier, et c'est loin
d'être neutre.
-Un tiers des émissions de carbone
sont liées à notre alimentation,
dont la moitié est associée
à notre consommation de viande.
Alors, en quelques décennies,
celle-ci a été multipliée par cinq.
Et juste un dernier chiffre,
Daphné :
un menu végétarien,
c'est 14 fois moins de carbone
qu'un repas
qui contient du boeuf.
-Je vais vous faire peur,
pour donner un ordre de grandeur,
il faut 13 500 l d'eau
pour un seul kilo de viande,
soit environ 192 douches.
La production de viande
est donc très gourmande en eau,
alors que le pays est à sec.
Qu'on le veuille ou non,
il va falloir modifier
notre rapport au vivant
si on veut continuer à évoluer
dans un monde vivable.
-Je crois
dans notre agriculture.
Depuis 5-6 ans,
on se bat pour elle, on avance.
Je crois en notre souveraineté
alimentaire, mais il est évident
qu'on aura des territoires
qu'il va falloir rapprocher
vers d'autres schémas agricoles.
Des productions agricoles connues
dans certains territoires
vont sans doute migrer
vers d'autres territoires.
Il va falloir réinventer
des modèles agricoles
dans d'autres territoires.
C'est une évidence.
-C'est la fin
de l'abondance.
Les nappes phréatiques sont
à leur plus bas historique,
la France connaît
des pénuries d'eau
et on prédit un été
plus aride que jamais.
Peut-on continuer
à manger autant de viande ?
Une filière si gourmande en eau
peut-elle continuer
à produire
à de telles échelles ?
Quelles sont les alternatives ?
Comment limiter notre consommation ?
Avec quels effets,
sans faire insulte aux agriculteurs
ni aux bouchers français,
sachant que 80 % des animaux
que nous consommons sont issus
de l'élevage intensif ?
Pour en débattre,
le député Renaissance,
éleveur et restaurateur en Gironde,
Pascal Lavergne,
le chef étoilé Thierry Marx,
l'agriculteur et député
européen Europe Ecologie-Les Verts,
Benoît Biteau. Bonjour.
Bienvenue à tous les trois.
Installez-vous.
Avant de vous donner la parole,
nous allons partir
dans le Finistère, à Landunvez,
où l'extension d'une mégaporcherie
concentre les tensions.
Cette ferme-usine est passée
de 9000 à 12 000 bêtes en 2017,
malgré plusieurs victoires
devant le tribunal administratif,
non suivies d'effets,
les opposants ont décidé de saisir
la justice pénale
pour contester l'extension
de cet élevage validé
par le préfet.
Le Tout oppose, un sujet
d'Alexis Breton et de Jawar Nadi.
-Landunvez,
à quelques dizaines de kilomètres
de Brest, en Bretagne.
Nombreux sont
les habitants de ce petit village
de 1400 âmes à se retrouver
ce soir-là à la salle des fêtes.
Le sujet est inflammable : pollution
et élevage intensif de porcs.
Les gendarmes sont là aussi. Ils ont
peut-être bien fait de venir,
car soudain,
un petit groupe arrive :
les éleveurs du coin.
Et ce n'était pas prévu.
*-Euh...
merci, merci d'être venus
nombreux ce soir,
pour, donc,
cette réunion publique.
-L'organisateur,
président de l'association
de défense de l'environnement local,
ne se démonte pas.
-Notre secteur, ici,
fait partie des endroits
où la concentration
de gros animaux d'élevage
est extrêmement importante.
-Entre 400 000 et 600 000 animaux
élevés industriellement,
quand même,
pour 48 000 habitants,
dans le Finistère Nord.
Les coupables désignés
vont rester debout,
au fond,
pendant toute la réunion.
Petite pression. Mais les habitants
ne se laissent pas impressionner.
*-Ca suffit.
C'est nous, les habitants.
C'est nous qui votons
et c'est nous qui payons les impôts.
Donc on a aussi le droit de vivre
dans des territoires... vivables.
*-Si on devait manger
tout le porc produit sur Landunvez
avec les habitants,
il faudrait manger 18 porcs par an.
Par personne, bien sûr.
Ca fait beaucoup.
-Le mot de trop
pour les éleveurs.
-A cause de la pollution,
certains habitants ont porté plainte
contre X pour mise en danger
de la vie d'autrui.
Cet éleveur, qui habite le village,
se sent visé.
-Vos chiffres, quand les diviseurs
sont pas les mêmes,
vos pourcentages,
vous savez bien qu'ils ont été faits
pour stigmatiser, pour montrer...
*-On a pris vos chiffres.
-Quand on prend de la production
et de la consommation,
et qu'on mélange tout ça, j'ai vu...
Je suis pas con non plus... Allez !
-Il est à la tête
d'une grande porcherie bretonne,
une exploitation
qui est devenue le symbole
de ce qui se passe
partout en Bretagne.
La première région agricole
française produit 60 % des porcs
et 35 % des volailles du pays,
avec son cortège de déjections
animales, de bactéries,
de nitrates, d'ammoniac.
La Bretagne est aussi dévorée
par la pollution : 99 % des rivières
de la région sont contaminées.
L'agriculture et l'élevage intensif
sont pointés du doigt,
un système dont la vocation
est de produire
un maximum de viande,
à des coûts
les plus faibles possibles,
et tant pis pour l'environnement.
A ce sujet, deux visions
s'opposent.
Pour les décrypter,
nous avons mis
face à face Agnès Le Brun,
conseillère régionale de Bretagne,
et Nicolas Legendre, journaliste
au Monde
et spécialiste de la région.
-C'est une fierté immense
de la Bretagne,
parce que c'est
dans son ADN de savoir
qu'elle peut être un garde-manger.
C'est une très belle vocation.
-Pour faire cette agriculture-là,
il a fallu modifier les écosystèmes.
Et donc, c'est l'intégralité
du vivant, en Bretagne,
la faune et la flore, qui a été
impacté par ce grand chambardement.
-Nous sommes
sur la Côte des Légendes :
le littoral autour de Landunvez
est très prisé
des touristes.
Mais cet environnement sauvage,
aux écosystèmes fragiles,
est en danger.
Voici la porcherie de la discorde,
qui se trouve aux portes du village.
En 2016, Philippe Bizien,
monsieur X,
a agrandi son exploitation
pour produire plusieurs milliers
de porcs de plus par an.
Une extension
que les défenseurs
de l'environnement souhaitent
faire annuler en justice.
Nous avons filmé ailleurs
l'autre réalité
de l'élevage industriel,
qu'il n'a pas voulu nous montrer :
des animaux sur caillebotis,
coupés de la nature et enfermés
dans des endroits
sans lumière naturelle,
les hangars aux truies entravées
24 heures sur 24,
quand elles ont des petits.
-On est avec ce qu'on appelle
les truies gestantes,
des truies qui vont avoir
des petits porcelets.
Ici, c'est un élevage
qui date déjà de...
des années 70.
Il y avait déjà mon grand-père,
mon père.
Moi, je me suis installé en 97.
Aujourd'hui, c'est un élevage
où il y a 850 reproducteurs.
Ca donne à peu près
25 000-26 000 cochons produits
par an.
-26 000 cochons,
et 60 tonnes d'excréments
et d'urines par jour.
-C'est les petits porcelets
qui ont été sevrés.
-Insupportable pour les habitants.
Ils accusent la ferme
de Philippe Bizien de contribuer
à la pollution de la région
et de mettre leur vie en danger.
-On le prend mal.
On investit beaucoup en temps,
en argent, sur le fait
que notre élevage soit
le plus vertueux possible.
On ressent un peu ça
comme du harcèlement.
-En Bretagne, des élevages
hors sol comme celui-ci,
il en existe plus de 1700.
-Culturellement,
la Bretagne est agricole
et vous ne trouverez pas
un Breton natif...
dont les ascendants n'ont pas
un rapport avec le monde agricole.
-Aujourd'hui, on a en Bretagne
110 millions d'animaux d'élevage,
sachant qu'on est 3,3 millions
d'humains.
La conséquence, c'est l'augmentation
des flux de nitrates,
à partir des sols,
puis avec le ruissellement,
dans les cours et plans d'eau.
-Alors, quelles conséquences
pour l'environnement ?
Penfoul,
à 2 km de Landunvez.
Une plage magnifique,
mais polluée par des bactéries
d'origine animale,
ce qui a provoqué plusieurs fois
sa fermeture l'été dernier,
pour le plus grand malheur
de Laurent Le Berre
et de ses amis,
Hubert et Christine,
ceux-là mêmes qui ont organisé
la réunion publique.
-T'as vu ce sable ? C'est là
que les gamins viennent tout l'été.
C'est là que j'ai appris à marcher.
-Ah, tiens !
-Ouais. A nager,
aussi.
-En ce qui me concerne,
je n'irai pas
ici à la plage
avec mes petits-enfants,
parce que c'est trop sale.
Ca peut être dangereux,
alors que moi, petite,
je venais ici, sans aucun...
Aucun risque.
Il y avait plein d'animaux.
-Absolument.
-Le problème vient de la rivière.
Il y a du lisier qui est aspergé
sur les champs.
Dès qu'une pluie survient,
les ruissellements vont finir
dans le point bas, la rivière,
et la rivière,
arrivant ici sur la plage,
charrie à la fois des alluvions
et des bactéries.
-Des bactéries
comme Escherichia coli,
qui provoque diarrhées
et vomissements,
et qui sont aussi néfastes
pour la biodiversité.
La rivière qui se déverse ici,
le Foul,
est jalonnée
par 31 fermes industrielles,
qui ont le droit d'épandre
sur les champs une partie
des centaines de tonnes de lisier
produit chaque jour.
Le reste est traité chimiquement
dans ces grandes cuves,
à ciel ouvert.
Pour la mairie de Landunvez,
aucun problème :
la pollution vient d'ailleurs.
Pour nous livrer les coupables,
l'adjointe au maire, Rachel Jaouen,
nous a donné rendez-vous
sur une plage à la baignade
interdite depuis 4 ans
pour cause de contamination sévère
aux bactéries animales,
encore elles.
Pour la seconder,
l'un des élus chargé
de la gestion des eaux,
Lucien Kerebel, aussi agriculteur.
-On a fait des analyses
sur l'intégralité du bassin versant,
des points d'analyse différents.
On ne détermine pas de pollution
réellement d'origine agricole.
En revanche, effectivement,
on a déterminé des pollutions
des oiseaux de mer.
-Tout à fait.
On a des colonies qui s'installent,
notamment
à marée basse,
et les analyses sont faites,
on va dire,
à mi-marée. Potentiellement,
il y a un lessivage de la plage
et on détecte ce genre d'excréments
dans les analyses.
-Les voilà, les responsables :
les méchants oiseaux qui défèquent
comme des malpolis
depuis des millénaires et qui,
tout à coup,
se mettent à les polluer.
Les écologistes dénoncent
ces analyses,
qui ne seraient pas faites
quand l'eau des champs,
fortement concentrée
en bactéries et en nitrates,
ruisselle vers les plages
lors des pluies. Il y a aussi
le précédent des algues vertes,
provoquées par les nitrates.
-Depuis le milieu des années 90,
l'INRA, l'IFREMER,
l'Institut de valorisation
des algues sont d'accord :
environ 95 %
des surplus de nitrates
dans les cours d'eau bretonne
sont liés aux activités agricoles
et là,
c'est un consensus scientifique.
-Qu'il y ait un problème
de pollution en Bretagne,
c'est possible, mais...
ne stigmatisons pas,
ne trouvons pas de bouc émissaire.
Donc, il ne faut pas imaginer que...
la méchante Bretagne,
les méchants agriculteurs bretons,
productivistes,
auraient un malin plaisir à détruire
ce qui fait la beauté de la Bretagne
aux yeux des touristes.
-Mme la conseillère régionale
reconnaît qu'il est possible
qu'il y ait un problème
de pollution. C'est déjà ça.
Pourrait-il y avoir aussi
un problème de santé publique ?
Dans le centre-ville de Landunvez,
Eric Le Fin, un retraité,
nous reçoit chez lui.
Il habite
à quelques centaines de mètres
de la porcherie
et il a peur pour sa santé.
-Je vais me faire un café.
Ici, j'ai des filtres.
J'ai un filtre à particules
et j'ai un filtre à charbon.
On ne boit que cette eau-là.
Tout est fait avec ça :
Le café...
Le pastis aussi, d'ailleurs !
-Comme Eric, de nombreux habitants
refusent de boire l'eau du robinet.
Ils ne font pas confiance
aux autorités
sanitaires, qui la considèrent
pourtant comme potable.
-Une population qui,
par précaution,
bien que l'eau soit aux normes,
refuse de la boire,
ça se trouve partout.
Ca relève du libre choix de chacun.
Mais dans tous les cas,
aujourd'hui,
aucune preuve n'est donnée
que ces eaux soient
de mauvaise qualité.
-Mais il n'y a pas que l'eau,
il y a l'air aussi, et là,
les données sont imparables.
-Si les gens
peuvent penser qu'on a de l'air pur,
on est surpris !
On est autant pollués
que certaines villes.
-La seule porcherie
du village rejette 33 tonnes
d'ammoniac par an,
un gaz qui se crée
lors de la fermentation du lisier.
Un gaz responsable de la pollution
de l'air aux particules fines,
qui favorise notamment
certains cancers.
La Bretagne en est
la première région émettrice.
-Il y a des acteurs
qui disent que le modèle agricole
dominant en Bretagne
n'est pas viable,
parce qu'il a tendance,
globalement, à épuiser les sols,
à détériorer
la qualité de l'eau,
détériorer la qualité de l'air,
donc il est difficilement soutenable
d'un point de vue environnemental,
écologique,
et économique.
-Fin de la réunion publique
à Landunvez.
*-A votre place,
à chacun d'entre vous,
je serais contre
mon élevage.
Tout ce qui a été dit
a été transformé ou déformé
pour l'essentiel, ou alors,
on fait un lien
entre des problématiques
et mon élevage,
qui n'est à aucun moment, avéré.
-Une petite demi-heure d'échanges
stériles entre éleveurs en colère
et habitants qui n'en peuvent plus.
-On n'a parlé
que de la pollution indirecte.
Par exemple, si on prend
les 33 tonnes d'ammoniac dans l'air,
vous pouvez pas le traiter,
mais nous, on peut pas l'ignorer.
-Des positions irréconciliables,
avant que les éleveurs
et leurs soutiens
ne sortent les éléments de langage
censés clore tout débat.
*-La production agricole s'effondre.
Elle est en train de s'effondrer.
Il est en train d'arriver
aujourd'hui à l'agriculture
ce qui est arrivé à l'industrie
il y a quelques années.
Dans 20 ou 30 ans,
il sera trop tard de dire
qu'il va falloir "réagricoliser"...
- comment dirais-je ? - la France.
-La souveraineté alimentaire,
l'argument massue.
-Vous mangerez américain,
si ça continue comme ça !
-Lorsqu'on n'est pas capable
de s'autosuffire,
on doit importer.
Alors, OK, on va arrêter de produire
en Bretagne et on va importer
du cochon de Chine.
C'est génial.
On l'a fait
pour le poulet brésilien.
Donc, celui qui a... veut faire
une dégustation à l'aveugle,
bienvenue, et on lui demandera
à la fin ce qu'il en aura pensé.
-Entre... 1960 et 2004,
le volume de production agricole
globale en France a doublé.
Or, dans le même temps,
la population française
n'a pas doublé.
Qu'est-ce qu'on a fait
de tous ces excédents ?
On les a surtout exportés.
*-Merci à tous.
-Deux visions du monde agricole,
qui ne sont pas près
de se rapprocher.
A Landunvez, le procureur
vient d'ouvrir une enquête
à la suite de la plainte contre X
pour mise en danger
de la vie d'autrui.
-Une réaction, peut-être,
à ce que l'on vient de voir ?
Vous êtes ingénieurs agronomes.
Pascal et Benoît ?
-Oui, mais écoutez,
c'est pas forcément
le modèle d'agriculture...
auquel j'aspire naturellement,
pour autant,
la façon dont l'agriculture
a été conduite depuis les années 60,
avec les lois d'orientation
sur l'agriculture,
où on a dit
aux agriculteurs :
"Produisez,
on s'occupera de vendre,
"mais il faut une alimentation
pas chère pour nos populations",
ça mène sans doute
à ce type d'excès.
-Aujourd'hui,
beaucoup y voient
un écocide caractérisé.
-Qu'ils aillent
faire un tour en Chine, où...
Là, vous avez vu,
on a des...
des porcheries
sur un seul niveau.
-En Chine, maintenant,
il y en a sur 25 étages.
-C'est des immeubles
de plusieurs étages.
Il y a des modèles...
qui sont encore pires.
-Oui,
mais bon...
-Est-ce qu'on est, aujourd'hui,
en capacité de revenir
à un modèle d'agriculture
quasi vivrière,
comme celle de mes grands-parents,
le modèle paysan, qui avaient...
une truie, qui faisaient
des porcelets, quelques-uns,
pas autant de truies que
dans une porcherie industrielle,
et après,
des porcelets qu'on élevait.
C'est plus du tout le modèle
de consommation,
donc il faut aussi
que le consommateur
prenne sa part de responsabilité
dans le développement
d'une agriculture
telle que celle
qui existe aujourd'hui.
Le consommateur,
depuis bien longtemps,
il se nourrit, il mange,
il a un apport énergétique,
protéique. Vous direz tout à l'heure
qu'il a un apport protéique
plus élevé que ses besoins,
j'en conviens,
mais aujourd'hui,
il y a un apport énergétique
et protéique pour les consommateurs
qui se fait
pour une valeur moins chère,
moins élevée qu'hier.
Vous croyez que ça se fait comment ?
-A l'heure
du réchauffement
climatique, de l'effondrement
de la biodiversité,
et de la pollution des eaux,
99 % des cours d'eau
et nappes phréatiques
en Bretagne
sont contaminés
par les pesticides,
20 % de Français,
12 millions de personnes,
ont bu, en 2021,
de l'eau non conforme.
Vous pensez que
ces élevages intensifs vont
dans le bon sens ?
Ce modèle représente-t-il
un horizon viable,
écologiquement ?
-Pour rebondir
sur ce que vient de dire Pascal,
on peut pas contester
que les orientations,
les politiques agricoles prises
ces 60 dernières années
ont conduit les agriculteurs
sur ce chemin-là.
Mon père faisait partie
de cette génération-là.
Je cherche pas
de têtes à mettre
sur le billot
ou des coupables.
Est-ce qu'on peut continuer
comme ça ?
Je vais prendre l'angle économique.
On dit que si on ne continue pas,
on va être obligés d'importer.
On importe déjà !
Aujourd'hui, au motif
qu'on veut exporter des céréales,
du porc, du boeuf, on importe
du soja d'Amérique latine !
Tout ça participe à accélérer
le changement climatique.
Il n'est pas contestable
que la concentration des animaux
émet du méthane, qui participe aussi
au changement climatique.
Il faut qu'on revisite tout ça.
Je reviens à l'économie.
On importe beaucoup.
Est-ce qu'on doit continuer
d'importer du soja ?
Doit-on doit remobiliser
nos surfaces agricoles,
trouver d'autres équilibres
de production ?
On exportera beaucoup moins
et on importera moins.
Si on relocalisait,
plutôt que de concentrer
des territoires sur des zones,
comme la Bretagne
sur l'élevage de porcs,
qui fait qu'on a
un excédent structurel d'azote
et de l'eau polluée ?
Ca coûte très cher de dépolluer.
A l'inverse, par exemple,
sur la Beauce,
il n'y a plus d'élevage,
on a aussi un excédent structurel
d'azote lié à la production
d'azote de synthèse qui participe
au changement climatique.
Relocalisons un peu les productions,
faisons moins d'élevage en Bretagne,
ramenons l'élevage
dans la Beauce,
sortons de ces excédents structurels
liés d'un côté
à des productions d'élevage,
de l'autre côté,
à l'utilisation
d'engrais de synthèse.
Vous verrez que ça coûte
beaucoup moins cher.
Quant à dire qu'on doit
passer par là pour atteindre
des produits pas chers
dans l'assiette des consommateurs
qui seraient les moins aisés,
ça veut dire quoi, ça ?
Ca veut dire que...
parce qu'on a un revenu modeste,
on doit manger
des produits de piètre qualité ?
-De la viande transformée.
-Moi, j'adhère pas à ce truc-là.
D'autant plus qu'en vérité,
les produits réputés pas chers
coûtent horriblement cher,
parce que quand on regarde
le poids de la dépollution,
des solutions curatives
qu'on doit apporter
pour réparer l'eau,
ressource majeure...
René Dumont, en 74,
nous alertait déjà
sur le fait que l'eau
était un produit extrêmement central
et extrêmement menacé.
Sur la pollution de l'air,
sur la réparation
de la biodiversité,
tout ça coûte horriblement cher.
Ces produits réputés pas chers
dans les rayons des grandes surfaces
sont horriblement chers
quand on y adosse
ces coûts externalisés.
-Bien sûr, indirects.
-Donc, si on payait la vérité
sur ces produits-là...
-Le coût environnemental.
-Le principe pollueur-payeur,
qui siège à la loi sur l'eau,
à la loi directive cadre
sur l'eau,
ces produits seraient
hors de prix.
Les seuls accessibles
à tous les porte-monnaie :
les produits bios.
-Thierry Marx,
la malbouffe,
c'est une économie du renoncement ?
-C'est la théorie du low cost,
imposée dans les années 70.
Vous renoncez à la qualité,
en échange, on fait des petits prix,
ce qui a amené, je suis d'accord,
une agriculture très productiviste,
pour descendre le prix,
écraser les marges des agriculteurs.
C'est aller dans le mur.
Il faut aller contre ça,
revenir
dans l'économie du bon.
C'est quoi, un bon produit ?
Son impact social,
environnemental et nutritionnel.
C'est ça, un bon produit,
avant qu'il soit bio.
Et puis, regarder les choses en face
et nos modes de consommation.
Mangeons mieux, moins,
passons du boeuf-carotte
au carotte-boeuf :
l'idée du 80-20.
-La bonne proportion,
c'est 80-20 ?
-Pour moi, c'est 80-20,
mais...
Je crois à la polyculture.
Moi, je suis pas
un spécialiste de l'agriculture.
Je suis un consommateur.
Du consommateur, je suis devenu
un mangeur. Si on travaille
avec le scolaire, très tôt,
sur réapprendre
à former à manger,
on aura moins de consommateurs
et on n'aura pas ça.
Encore une fois,
cette théorie du renoncement
liée au low cost
est une économie mortifère
pour l'agriculture,
mais pas que.
-On a deux éleveurs
et deux agriculteurs
parmi nous. Justement,
vous êtes fils
et petit-fils d'agriculteur,
et avez hérité
de la ferme familiale :
255 ha de maïs...
-Pas franchement hérité.
Il a fallu que je fasse le chèque.
-D'accord.
Vous êtes passé d'un modèle intensif
à bout de souffle
à une ferme rentable
sans labour
ni pesticides.
C'est donc possible.
Et sans engrais de synthèse.
Possible ?
-C'est ce que je voulais démontrer :
dans ma vie professionnelle,
avant de devenir paysan,
j'ai fait un peu de recherche,
j'étais scientifique
et j'ai côtoyé des gens
qui avaient réussi
cette transition.
Quand mon père arrive
à l'âge de la retraite,
je dis : "Je retrousse les manches
et je tente l'aventure."
C'est du passage à l'acte, pour moi.
Je suis passé de prescripteur
à un acteur de terrain.
Ce que je voulais démontrer,
c'est qu'en partant de là,
avec un très lourd endettement...
C'est ce qu'on nous met
comme point de blocage pour...
engager la transition,
à partir de là,
avec un très fort endettement,
je dis : "On y va,
"on part
sur des logiques agroécologiques
"et on démontre
que la transition est possible."
Elle apporte une réponse
sur le plan de l'écologie,
sur le plan de l'économie,
parce que l'économie est pertinente
et sur le plan social.
On est heureux,
quand on fait les choses autrement.
-Vous dites que
c'est rémunérateur et résilient.
Est-ce que l'agroécologie
peut nous nourrir ?
-Je dis déjà qu'il ne faut pas
opposer les modèles
les uns aux autres.
Si Benoît Biteau a fait
cette transition,
en passant
d'une génération à l'autre,
c'est parce qu'il avait réfléchi
à cette question.
Aujourd'hui,
beaucoup de gens
sont dans cette réflexion.
Les agriculteurs
ne sont pas sourds
à ce qu'ils entendent
du monde extérieur.
Beaucoup s'interrogent.
Je voudrais revenir...
-Beaucoup s'interrogent,
mais en réalité, la France
a perdu 100 000 agriculteurs
en 10 ans.
Parmi eux, beaucoup d'éleveurs.
Paradoxalement, la surface agricole
est restée stable.
La taille des exploitations
augmente,
alors que
ses effectifs se réduisent.
Le marché se concentre
entre les mains de quelques-uns,
au détriment
des petites exploitations.
C'est pas les agriculteurs
qui sont en cause.
C'est l'agrobusiness,
l'élevage intensif,
les grosses exploitations.
-Pourquoi
les exploitations
ne sont pas reprises ?
Tout simplement
parce qu'elles laissent
trop peu de marge,
trop peu de revenus
à ceux qui seraient
en capacité de les reprendre.
Moi, j'ai créé
ma propre exploitation.
J'en ai quand même bavé.
C'est loin d'être simple.
-Mais vous avez
un restaurant.
Vous avez fait du circuit court.
Votre modèle est résilient.
-Il est particulier.
Sincèrement...
-C'est de la fourche à l'assiette.
-Je pense qu'il faut
des modèles d'exploitation
qui soient peut-être
moins spécialisés.
Le modèle de polyculture
qu'on avait traditionnellement
dans l'Entre-deux-Mers
ou en Gironde,
puisque c'est de ce département
que je suis l'élu,
il n'existe plus,
et c'est dommage.
-Vous dites que
l'élevage paysan est mis à mal
par la production industrielle.
-Pas par la production
industrielle,
mais par le fait que
les agriculteurs n'ont pas
une rémunération correcte
des produits
qu'ils mettent en oeuvre,
réalisent.
A un moment donné,
ça conduit à se spécialiser
pour pouvoir tirer
les coûts de production
vers le bas.
Finalement, on débouche
sur des modèles qui sont
complètement industrialisés,
parce qu'il y a une concentration
des exploitations.
C'est le constat.
-Pour revenir
sur ce que fait
M. Biteau...
Vous produisez quoi,
pour vous en sortir ?
C'est quoi, la solution ?
-Je suis en polyculture
et polyélevage.
Ma structure fait 208 ha exactement.
Il y a 110 ha de prairie,
puisque j'élève des herbivores.
Ecoutez la révolution
que je propose :
nourrir des herbivores
avec de l'herbe.
Ils ne mangent que ça.
Je ne suis pas dépendant
de la production de maïs
qui pose
les problèmes connus
sur la ressource en eau.
C'est d'actualité,
l'irrigation
du maïs.
-Sans blague.
-Egalement du soja qui vient
de l'autre côté de l'Atlantique.
En France,
quand on prend 1 ha de maïs
pour nourrir des animaux,
on crée une dépendance
de 1 ha de soja
outre-Atlantique.
Je nourris mes animaux
avec de l'herbe.
J'ai créé des conditions
pour que ça fonctionne.
Mon rectangle d'herbe
qui sert
à nourrir mes herbivores
n'est pas coté
à la bourse de Chicago.
Cette autonomie-là me donne
une liberté économique
qui est formidable.
C'est ça, la résilience,
y compris
sur le plan économique.
C'est de retrouver de l'autonomie.
Je produis
de la viande de bovin,
de la viande de chèvre,
des chevreaux.
Je produis du lait de chèvre,
transformé en produits laitiers
vendus à la ferme.
Toutes mes productions animales
sont vendues à la ferme.
Quelques oeufs de poules pondeuses.
Pour l'équilibre agronomique
- c'est technique -
j'ai des baudets du Poitou
qui pâturent
avec des chèvres
et des chevaux de trait
avec des vaches.
-Vous maintenez les prairies.
-C'est là où je veux en venir.
Aujourd'hui,
on montre l'élevage
comme une activité qui participe
au changement climatique.
Quand cet élevage,
dans une approche globale,
entretient des espaces prairiaux...
J'élève sur une réserve
naturelle régionale.
Mon fils,
sur une réserve nationale.
On préserve
des espaces remarquables
en termes de capacité à séquestrer
les gaz à effet de serre.
C'est parce qu'ils sont
entretenus par l'élevage
qu'ils ont ces facultés.
Cet élevage,
ça peut en choquer certains,
participe à l'atténuation
du changement climatique.
Le bilan carbone de ma structure
participe à cette atténuation.
Chez mon fils, c'est pareil,
donc vous voyez bien
que c'est fondamental.
Au-delà de ça, ces espaces
hébergent de la biodiversité
remarquable,
dans un contexte d'effondrement
de la biodiversité.
On parle beaucoup de l'eau,
en ce moment.
C'est précisément sur ces prairies,
qui sont souvent humides,
qu'on peut stocker l'eau longtemps,
pour que cette eau ait le temps
de remplir
les nappes souterraines
et puisse
satisfaire tous les usages de l'eau,
que ce soit l'eau potable,
que ce soit la biodiversité
ou, pourquoi pas, de l'eau utilisée
pour l'irrigation.
Ca devient manichéen,
entre élever avec du maïs
et du soja, d'un côté,
le cercle vicieux
sur le changement climatique,
la biodiversité et la santé,
et, de l'autre côté,
des éleveurs qui pratiquent
un élevage herbager,
avec des herbivores
qui mangent de l'herbe,
où on prend soin de la biodiversité,
du climat, de la santé.
-L'agroécologie est
indispensable ?
-Economiquement,
c'est pertinent.
Les coûts sont faibles.
-Je défends vraiment
cette agriculture.
C'est mon coeur de métier.
Travaillant pour la gastronomie,
je défends ça.
Ce que je défends aussi,
c'est qu'il y a un public en face.
Il ne faut pas qu'il y ait
un consommateur, mais un mangeur.
La France vit
une fracture sociale
très dure, avec une alimentation
à deux vitesses,
pour les gens qui comprennent
ce qu'ils mangent,
qui ont un reste à vivre
suffisant,
et les gens qui n'ont pas
un reste à vivre suffisant,
qui se contentent
de l'ultratransformé,
car, le 10 du mois,
on est à l'euro près.
Il y a un vrai travail à faire,
qui est politique,
au sens étymologique du terme,
sur cette problématique
de l'alimentation au global,
pour qu'il y ait du bon
pour tous.
Si je n'ai pas un public en face
pour comprendre
ce type d'agriculture,
si j'ai des consommateurs
qui achètent à l'euro près,
c'est un vrai débat.
A chaque fois, qui écrase les marges
de l'agriculteur ?
L'agriculture productiviste existe,
car il y a un réseau
de distribution pour ça.
Quand on fait une variable
d'ajustement du pouvoir d'achat
sur l'alimentation...
L'alimentation n'est pas
un carburant.
Ca n'a rien à voir.
Ca a des conséquences
sur l'impact social
et, évidemment,
sur la santé des populations.
-Ne faut-il pas
flécher les subventions
de la PAC
vers l'agroécologie
et non pas vers l'industrie ?
-Une orientation est prise,
petit à petit,
par rapport à ça.
Oui, le plan protéines est petit.
Il faut voir le chemin parcouru.
Il reste du chemin à parcourir,
mais il faut mesurer le chemin
qui est parcouru.
Je crois, tel que l'a décrit
Benoît Biteau...
Je suis ravi d'entendre,
de la part d'un élu écologiste,
le discours qu'il a tenu
par rapport aux bovins,
moi qui suis éleveur bovin.
Entre ce qu'on dit dans l'hémicycle
et ce que j'entends ici, à LCP,
dans les locaux du palais Bourbon...
De la part d'un élu écologiste,
ça me fait quand même plaisir.
-Mais c'est pas le même modèle.
-Le modèle herbager
qu'il a mis en place,
c'est le modèle parfait
pour l'élevage bovin viande.
Il ne faut pas jeter
le bébé avec l'eau du bain.
En tout cas, il ne faut pas balancer
notre élevage bovin,
tel qu'on le critique,
de façon trop systématique,
trop rapide.
Les bovins en prennent
plein la tête.
-Pascal Lavergne, la viande,
c'est 5 kg de légumineuses produits
pour 1 kg de viande.
Ne devrait-on pas libérer fissa
de l'espace agricole
pour nourrir
non pas les bêtes,
mais les humains ?
60 % de nos terres, en Europe,
servent à nourrir le bétail.
On marche sur la tête, non ?
-On est d'accord.
Thierry Marx nous dira
ce qu'il en pense.
Je ne mange pas que pour ingérer
des protéines et de l'énergie.
Je mange aussi pour le plaisir,
pour une gastronomie
qui s'inscrit dans l'histoire
du patrimoine français.
Cette gastronomie est aussi
en capacité d'évoluer.
Je pense que des grands chefs
comme Thierry Marx
n'ont pas une part
de responsabilité,
mais peuvent se sentir
investis d'une mission
pour pouvoir faire découvrir,
au travers
d'autres pratiques gastronomiques,
des choses.
Ca, c'est aussi
un volet de l'histoire
qu'il faudra intégrer.
J'insiste pour pouvoir répondre
sur les bovins.
Les bovins, aujourd'hui,
tels qu'ils sont élevés
dans notre pays et en Europe,
ça n'a rien à voir
avec les "feedlots"
que vous trouvez
outre-Atlantique.
Aujourd'hui,
nous devons encore défendre
le modèle
d'élevage bovin français
qui s'appuie
principalement
sur l'herbager,
qui valorise les légumineuses,
qui fixe l'azote de l'air
et qui évite d'avoir recours
à la fertilisation azotée
issue de la pétrochimie.
On doit revoir les assolements.
On doit revoir
tout ce système prairial
de prairies naturelles
qui doivent intégrer
des légumineuses,
plusieurs types de graminées.
C'est aussi la diversité
qui permettra de maintenir
l'élevage français.
-Dans une ferme-usine,
une vache pollue. Une vache au pré,
ça fertilise ?
-Une vache au pré,
ça rend un service également
dans le cycle de l'eau
et en termes de biodiversité,
en fonction du milieu
dans lequel elle est.
Dans le milieu poitevin,
il y a un certain équilibre
de biodiversité.
Quand on est
sur les coteaux du Cantal,
il y a encore un autre système
de biodiversité.
Les bovins, c'est des ruminants.
Ils ont un système digestif
bien particulier.
Ils ont aussi leur rôle
à jouer dans l'équilibre agronomique
des sols.
C'est pour ça que
la non-spécialisation des bassins...
Il faudrait qu'on revienne
à des systèmes
de polyculture-élevage
qui permettent d'allier
une fertilisation agronomique
issue de l'élevage,
plutôt que d'avoir recours
à de l'engrais chimique.
Je crois aussi à ça,
mais on a été trop loin.
On va revenir en arrière.
Les agriculteurs le savent.
Ils sont prêts à le faire.
Il faut leur laisser du temps.
-Venons-en à la viande de synthèse.
Après les burgers végétaux hi-tech,
on parle de viande cellulaire
ou viande de synthèse.
Mettre de la technologie
dans notre assiette,
est-ce une bonne idée ?
Réponse dans le Climatoscope
de Raphaël Hitier.
-Est-ce que
c'est une bonne idée ?
Peut-être, mais c'est clairement pas
pour le goût qu'on fait ça.
L'intérêt principal
de la viande artificielle...
Avant toute chose,
je peux définir ce que c'est.
Ca consiste, non pas à prélever
de la viande sur un animal vivant,
mais juste à prélever des cellules
qu'on va mettre en culture
dans des incubateurs.
On va mélanger ça
avec des ingrédients qui vont bien.
-Ca vous rend malade.
-Je préfère voir naître
un veau,
quitte à ce que
la vache me foute
un coup de tête pour que
je m'approche pas du veau.
Je trouve ça plus rigolo,
plus sympa
que regarder des cellules grossir.
-C'est pas la même histoire.
-L'intérêt
de cette approche-là
étant de fournir
un apport en protéines,
en évitant
de tuer des animaux.
Si on croit les chiffres
qui sont donnés
par un des pionniers
de la viande in vitro,
avec les cellules d'une seule vache,
on peut produire
jusqu'à 175 millions de steaks,
l'équivalent de 400 000 vaches.
Du point de vue de la vache
qui va à l'abattoir,
la viande artificielle,
c'est mieux.
Du point de vue écologique,
est-ce que c'est différent ?
Il faut bien se représenter
ce qu'est cette activité
qui émerge.
C'est une activité industrielle.
On va pas fabriquer
de la viande artificielle
sur un coin de paillasse,
dans un laboratoire familial.
Une des plus grosses entreprises
du secteur
conçoit des bioréacteurs
qui font 250 000 litres.
On est vraiment sur de l'industrie,
donc avec de la machine,
des machines
qui consomment de l'énergie
et, du coup,
qui vont envoyer
du carbone dans l'atmosphère.
L'intérêt climatique
ou écologique
de la viande artificielle
n'est pas
totalement avéré.
Pour l'instant,
personne ne communique
là-dessus.
Il y a du secret industriel
derrière tout ça
et pas d'évaluation indépendante
sur ces questions-là.
-Il y a eu, au Sénat...
On a eu une réponse
au Sénat.
On voit que c'est pour nous couper
du monde du vivant.
Le danger,
c'est la manipulation des masses
avec ça.
On voit bien que c'est porté...
90 millions de dollars
ont été levés.
C'est plutôt sur la Chine.
Ces produits ne sont pas
environnementalement
responsables
et coupent du lien
avec le vivant.
C'est dangereux.
-Vous avez été le chef de file
de la cuisine moléculaire.
Vous êtes à la tête
d'un laboratoire
qui vise à améliorer
le contenu de nos assiettes.
Vous vous êtes penché
sur la question ?
-On a regardé ça de près.
Moi, je suis pas chercheur.
Je ne suis qu'un artisan.
Je travaille avec des chercheurs.
On a regardé un petit peu.
On s'est dit :
"Pourquoi pas ? Ca marche.
"Ca fonctionne.
Pourquoi faire ?"
Le danger,
c'est de nous couper du vivant,
ce qui nous a pénalisés,
dans les années 70,
quand on s'est coupés
du monde agricole
et qu'on s'est dit
"J'achète des produits
"sans connaître l'agriculteur".
C'était dangereux.
Ce qui nous interpelle
beaucoup,
c'est de voir les puissances
qui sont intéressées
par ce business
qui est de l'ultratransformé.
Vous maîtrisez totalement
ce que doit manger un individu
en le déconnectant
de ce monde du vivant.
Moi, je trouve ça dangereux,
aussi comme outil de manipulation.
Laisser croire que c'est
pour des causes environnementales...
Les noms de ces sociétés
sont intéressants :
"Gourmet" ceci, etc.
Il y a un piège marketing,
là-dedans.
C'est très dangereux.
Bien que je n'aime pas le mot
"steak végétal",
je peux comprendre l'idée d'avoir
cette réaction de Maillard
sur un poêlage de légumes.
Pourquoi pas ?
Sur ces viandes in vitro,
il y a un danger de manipulation.
Ca m'inquiète beaucoup.
-Il y a surtout
une inconnue importante,
pour l'instant :
il y a peu de communication
de la part des industriels
sur les ingrédients utilisés.
Ca questionne sur la santé,
l'environnement.
Il y a eu une tribune dans Le Monde
de la part de scientifiques
qui réclament un peu
de transparence là-dessus
pour pouvoir évaluer les choses
correctement.
L'essentiel des gens
qui communiquent
sont ceux qui se lancent
dans cette activité.
-Remarquez qu'il y a
très peu de publications
scientifiques.
Les cellules souches,
on ne sait pas
où elles vont être prélevées,
comment elles vont l'être.
Il y a une opacité absolue.
Le danger de l'alimentation,
c'est pas simplement
de parler de gastronomie
et de chefs
qui auraient un rôle
de diriger les gens.
C'est transversal,
c'est-à-dire que
le cadre éducationnel
du bien-manger,
de devenir un mangeur,
ça commence en famille,
bien sûr,
mais ça se fait à l'école.
Dans l'apprentissage
du savoir-manger,
il y a toute une étude
de culture générale à faire :
replacer
le cours de cuisine
à l'école, pour y trouver
le mangeur de dans 20 ans.
Sinon, l'agriculture,
ce que fait monsieur,
n'aura pas de sens,
car il n'y aura pas de public.
-On va parler
des cantines scolaires,
de la restauration d'entreprise
et des collectivités locales
qui sont un levier majeur
pour réduire la part de la viande.
Qu'est-ce qu'on attend
pour le faire ?
Il y a 1 écolier sur 10
qui se voit
proposer un repas végétarien
par semaine à la cantine.
-Ca dérange les codes,
les cercles établis
par d'autres, avant,
des centrales d'achat,
des façons de travailler,
de replacer un véritable artisan
au coeur de la cuisine,
peut-être de casser
les cuisines centrales pour se dire
qu'on a intérêt à remettre...
Nous, ça nous est arrivé,
dans un lycée en Touraine,
où le président de région
a accepté
qu'on remette au coeur de ce lycée
un artisan
qui a le droit
de produire des choses,
qui peut acheter dans des filières
beaucoup plus courtes.
On a redonné une attractivité.
Il faut 15 ans.
-Je vous propose de regarder
ce qui se passe près d'Angoulême.
La cheffe Laure Mardoc
a lancé Cap Veggie
qui apprend aux chefs cuisiniers
à végétaliser leurs menus,
notamment dans les cantines.
La restauration collective,
c'est 10 millions de repas par jour,
en France :
un levier aussi massif qu'efficace
pour nous apprendre
à manger mieux et autrement.
Alexis Breton et Franck Vrignon
ont suivi cette initiative
soutenue par la région
Nouvelle-Aquitaine.
Le monde de demain
ouvre l'appétit.
Reportage.
-Aujourd'hui, près d'Angoulême,
la capitale française
de la bande dessinée,
pas de feuille blanche ni de stylo,
mais casseroles et cuillères.
Dans ce lycée professionnel...
-Je vous réunis.
-...la cheffe Laure Mardoc...
-Du coup, on va faire...
-...va former
à la cuisine végétarienne
des chefs de cantine scolaire
un peu dissipés.
-Des oeufs de lapin ?
-Vous, vous avez l'air drôle.
Il y avait un lapin en peluche.
On lui a dit que
c'était des oeufs de lapin.
Elle a dit à son mari :
"Tu vois que ça existe,
les oeufs de lapin."
-Cet homme et une dizaine
de ses collègues de la région
vont apprendre
une chose importante :
il n'y a pas que les saucisses,
dans la vie.
-Nous voici en cuisine.
Répartissez-vous
sur les plans de travail.
On va faire
les recettes végétariennes
qu'on va mettre en production,
aujourd'hui.
Voilà.
Allez-y,
à la pratique en cuisine,
et amusez-vous bien.
Tout est frais.
On fait tout en frais.
-Ces élèves sont des chefs
à l'ancienne, pourrait-on dire :
viande et poisson
à tous les repas.
Ils n'ont pas beaucoup d'idées
pour travailler les légumes.
Figurez-vous que
le pied de brocoli est délicieux.
-Tu vois l'écorce ?
-Le pourtour s'enlève. D'accord.
-En fait, c'est la partie
la plus douce du brocoli.
-Au menu de la formation,
pois chiches,
lentilles et haricots
de toutes les couleurs.
Des légumineuses riches en protéines
qui vont remplacer la viande
dans les menus des cantines,
encore faut-il réussir
à convaincre les cuisiniers.
-Galettes de haricots rouges
tex-mex.
-Vous connaissez cette recette ?
-Pas du tout.
C'est un essai pour moi.
J'ai jamais fait ça.
-Vous êtes convaincu ou pas ?
-C'est quand je goûterai
que je saurai
si je suis convaincu.
-Pour Thierry,
l'enjeu de la cuisine végétarienne
est aussi ailleurs.
-Nous, quand on fait
du végétal
dans des lycées,
comme j'ai une population
de garçons, ça nourrit plus
la poubelle que les élèves,
parce que, les élèves,
s'ils n'ont pas leur viande...
C'est pas leur truc.
Ils aiment la viande.
Les rugbymen aiment la viande.
Avec le végétal,
ils ont pas l'impression
d'avoir mangé.
Pourtant, il y a
des protéines végétales
qui ont le même apport
que la viande.
Il faut arriver
à leur faire comprendre ça.
-C'est la région
qui organise cet atelier
pour respecter la loi.
Depuis fin 2019, les établissements
scolaires français
ont l'obligation
de proposer à leurs élèves
un menu végétarien
par semaine.
Une disposition combattue
par certains
à coups de barbecue et de saucisson.
-On a un public féminin
qui est parfois moins réticent
à aller vers ces propositions,
où il y a moins ce côté
"Je dois bâtir mes muscles", etc.,
du coup, ce côté viril
lié à la viande.
Et puis, il y a la question
de la classe sociale.
Les classes populaires
mangent beaucoup plus
de viande.
En fait, l'assiette,
elle est politique,
quelque part.
-Politique et cruciale
pour la planète. Petit rappel :
1 kg de boeuf produit 44 fois plus
de gaz à effet de serre
que 1 kg de légumineuses.
-Vous risquez rien.
-Avec un oeuf mayo,
ça doit être bon.
-Selon des études officielles,
se passer de viande rouge
et servir trois repas végétariens
par semaine dans toutes les cantines
réduirait de moitié
leurs émissions de CO2.
Une solution simple et immédiate,
rien qu'en France.
-La restauration collective,
c'est entre 3 et 4 milliards
de repas par an.
Il y a un effet massif.
L'impact va être démultiplié
en restauration collective scolaire,
car il y a un effet de long terme.
C'est des jeunes qui vont peut-être,
pour toute leur vie,
adorer le dahl de lentilles
ou la quiche aux légumes.
C'est un levier
de transformation
énorme
des comportements alimentaires
et du modèle agricole.
-Alors, pour changer la donne,
nos chefs doivent arriver
à concocter des recettes
à même de ravir les papilles
et les estomacs
de l'ensemble des jeunes Français.
Musique légère
...
-Ciseler les carottes.
-Des plats comme les lasagnes.
-Je mets au four ?
-Oui.
-Qui pourrait dire non
au bourguignon de champignons,
aux fajitas de haricots rouges...
-Elle est bien. C'est bien.
-...ou aux pois chiches
à la normande ?
-Il faut que ça ait du goût.
-Où sont les haricots rouges ?
-Ouah, ouah, ouah !
-Là, on n'est pas
sur de la restauration collective.
C'est un plat signature.
-Ca prouve que,
en collectivité,
on peut se faire plaisir,
donc faire aussi
un peu de gastro.
-Il y a une qualité
de cuisinier,
en restauration collective,
qui est extraordinaire.
-Là, vous avez le summum.
Bruno, c'est le must des musts.
-C'est pour ça
qu'il a la veste rouge.
-Après lui, c'est moi.
-Voici enfin venu
le moment le plus important
de la journée :
la dégustation.
-Bon, on peut manger.
-Ouais. Je vous invite
à prendre une assiette.
-C'est très bon.
Avec les champignons
comme ça,
cuisinés,
on croirait même que...
Il y a un petit goût
de viande, de rôti.
-C'est très bon.
Très, très bon.
Ca, c'est vendable,
dans un lycée.
C'est un truc
que les élèves aimeraient.
C'est très bon.
-Ils ont l'air de se régaler.
J'ai l'impression
que ça se passe plutôt bien.
J'entends de bons échos,
donc c'est plutôt bon.
-En deux ans,
Laure a formé plus de 500 chefs,
et il faut savoir
qu'ils sont maîtres
en leur cuisine.
Ils ont le droit
de proposer plusieurs
repas végétariens par semaine.
Ces chefs peuvent devenir
des pionniers
de la transition écologique
et mijoter un avenir meilleur
aux générations futures.
-On l'a compris : la révolution
se fera par l'assiette.
Contrairement à une idée reçue,
largement relayée,
y compris
par le gouvernement,
les menus sans viande
ne renforcent pas
les inégalités.
Ils rééquilibrent
le repas des enfants
les plus défavorisés,
car ce sont eux
qui mangent le plus de viande.
-Oui. Manger moins de viande
- l'OMS nous le dit -
c'est moins de pathologies
liées à la surconsommation
de viande.
Encore une fois,
il faut parler de surconsommation.
Nos arrière-grands-parents mettaient
un poulet à rôtir le dimanche
et une viande dans la soupe
de temps en temps.
Ils étaient dans la notion
de flexitarisme.
Laisser croire aux gens
qu'ils sont riches,
car ils mangent une viande
à coût bas,
ça n'a pas de sens.
Aujourd'hui,
on rééquilibre ça.
Le végétal a un apport
équilibre alimentaire, plaisir,
bien-être, santé.
Je ne peux pas parler de santé,
en tant qu'artisan,
mais tous les médecins
nous le confirment.
Tous les médecins que je rencontre,
à qui j'écris, nous disent :
"Effectivement,
réduisons la viande,
"parce que c'est trop."
Cette surconsommation
crée des pathologies.
-Ces contrevérités
sur le végétarisme,
qui serait antisocial
ou nuisible à la santé,
ça vous énerve ?
-Le marqueur social...
-Même si vous êtes éleveurs.
-...ce n'est plus
l'accès à la viande.
Ceux qui ont les revenus
les plus modestes
mangent trop de viande.
Le marqueur social,
c'est l'accès aux fruits et légumes.
Je voulais juste revenir
sur le lien.
On pense que les éleveurs
sont juste dans la relation
d'élever leurs animaux.
Je peux vous assurer
que la relation avec les animaux
est un lien qui nous élève.
Et puis, on parle
de biodiversité sauvage.
Je n'élève que des races locales
et à faible effectif.
Le jour où il n'y a plus d'élevage,
ce patrimoine disparaît
avec l'élevage,
donc il faut raison garder.
Bien sûr qu'il faut
radicalement baisser
l'élevage industriel,
le faire disparaître...
-Pour arriver
à la neutralité carbone
en 2050,
il va falloir réduire le cheptel.
-Oui, réduire la consommation.
Les deux sujets sont liés.
On ne pourra pas
réduire l'activité d'élevage,
si on ne réduit pas
la consommation de produits carnés
et laitiers.
Il faudra réduire
notre consommation,
mais le marqueur social
n'est plus
l'accès à la viande.
C'est très important.
Il faudra appliquer scrupuleusement
le principe
pollueur-payeur
et on verra que
seuls les produits
de très bonne qualité,
basés sur des pratiques agricoles
qui reviennent aux fondamentaux,
feront que ces produits
seront accessibles à tous.
Du coup,
on aura un cercle vertueux
sur la biodiversité
et la santé.
-Le bon pour tous,
c'est très important,
et le marqueur social aussi.
Vraiment.
Je termine juste là-dessus.
Sur un éleveur, un agriculteur,
c'est aussi
des économies symbiotiques,
des économies à plat
qui vivent entre elles
et qui montrent que
cette relation au patrimoine,
ce lien du vivant...
-C'est un lien qui nous élève.
-Donner envie à des gens en vie.
-Une taxe sur la viande
ou une TVA à 0 %
sur de la viande paysanne,
par exemple,
ce serait une bonne idée ?
-Une TVA à 0 %
sur la viande,
pour que les distributeurs
se la mettent dans la poche,
c'est pas nécessaire.
-Non, sur l'élevage paysan.
-Oui. Il faut se méfier.
Tout le monde n'y a pas accès.
Des gens vivent
dans les métropoles.
Il faut qu'ils puissent
avoir accès à la ferme.
C'est pas aussi évident.
Je pense qu'il faut donner un accès
à la viande de qualité,
le plus possible,
également aux classes sociales
défavorisées.
Je souhaite qu'on continue
cette expérimentation
qui a été mise en place
par la majorité précédente,
à laquelle j'appartiens,
sur les repas végétariens.
N'allons pas
d'un excès à l'autre.
Laissons les choses
se faire petit à petit.
On a eu un exemple
de la région Aquitaine.
Hier,
on avait la possibilité
d'imposer des choses
par le biais de la niche écolo
présentée à l'Assemblée.
Nous n'avons pas
voulu aller
vers l'obligation.
Je vois que la région
Aquitaine s'empare de ça.
-Angoulême.
-Qu'ils continuent à le faire.
On les aidera à aller dans ce sens.
N'opposons pas les systèmes.
Conservons les équilibres.
On sait où les excès mènent,
dans quel domaine que ce soit.
-Donc la révolution viendra
des territoires.
Pour appréhender l'avenir,
on peut aussi regarder le passé.
C'est souvent éclairant.
Charlotte Epale est allée fouiller
dans les archives de l'INA
et nous a exhumé ceci.
Hier encore, c'est notre coup d'oeil
dans le rétro.
-L'entreprise agricole ne peut plus
être gérée comme autrefois.
Il faut que le chef
d'entreprise agricole,
en 1964,
gère son entreprise agricole
exactement de la même façon
qu'un industriel.
Ils cherchent actuellement
la meilleure formule pour eux,
les solutions
qui vont leur permettre
d'atteindre cette efficacité
sur le plan économique.
Différentes formules
ont été proposées,
soit dans le cadre
des grandes entreprises,
des entreprises
à structure familiale,
qui semblent progresser
de plus en plus
vers des structures d'exploitation
en commun,
qui leur permettront
vraisemblablement d'arriver
à cette notion d'entreprise,
de véritable entreprise
agricole.
-Cette succession
de questions économiques,
techniques et humaines
qu'il faut résoudre
peut sembler lointaine
à la maîtresse de maison
qui a aussi ses problèmes.
Musique intrigante
Pourtant, tirer les agriculteurs
de l'inconfort
dans lequel ils vivent trop souvent,
leur permettre
de s'établir, de fonder un foyer,
cela concerne la nation entière,
les habitants des villes
comme ceux des campagnes.
Si les jeunes ruraux
ne peuvent pas connaître
une existence meilleure,
une certaine joie de vivre,
ils partiront de leur ferme,
et c'est la production
qui en souffrira.
Musique enjouée
...
-Le consommateur,
on ne l'ignore pas.
C'est notre meilleur client.
Sans lui,
inutile de penser
à la viande.
S'intéresser à lui,
c'est prendre
un certain nombre de décisions
pour qu'il ne manque pas
de viande dans l'avenir.
-Bref, plus que jamais,
le développement de l'élevage
conditionne
notre plat de viande
quotidien.
-Je vous sens émus.
Avant de conclure,
voici quelques livres
pour aller plus loin.
"L'avenir de la planète
commence dans notre assiette",
de Jonathan Safran Foer,
soulève le rôle
de l'élevage intensif
dans la crise climatique.
Lecture à compléter
par son essai choc, paru en 2009,
mais toujours d'actualité :
"Faut-il manger des animaux ?",
édité à l'Olivier.
Vous pouvez lire "Manger moins
(et mieux) de viande",
de Gilles Daveau,
chez Actes Sud,
ou comment le moins
se transforme en plus.
Je vous engage à vous plonger
dans la fable animalière
de Lucie Rico,
"Le chant du poulet sous vide",
qui interroge le lien
entre ce qu'on consomme et produit,
comment on compose avec ce système.
On appelle ça
la dissonance cognitive.
C'est un livre P.O.L
qui a été couronné par le Prix
du roman d'écologie 2021.
A lire ou à relire,
le très beau roman de Serge Joncour,
"Nature humaine",
disponible chez Flammarion.
Enfin, pour terminer,
cette remarquable enquête
de Nicolas Legendre.
Le journaliste du Monde
a enquêté pendant sept ans
sur l'agrobusiness breton.
C'est aux éditions Arthaud.
C'est dans toute bonne librairie.
En conclusion,
notre bulletin de vote
se trouve aussi dans notre assiette.
Winston Churchill disait :
"Mieux vaut
"prendre le changement
par la main,
"avant qu'il nous prenne
par la gorge." Merci à vous.
-MERCI.
-Rendez-vous le mois prochain,
sur LCP, évidemment.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
Générique
...